hi my name's Sofia Rosemarie homeless
Luna has to be now and you're watching
planet rise where we try all the latest
products and trends so today I'm going
to be testing out the new girl
foundation just woken up in my hotel
room in London I'm still in my pajamas
as you can say I have a really busy day
ahead we've got a few costumes and to
shoot at the end of the day I'm gonna be
doing some shopping and just going to my
favorite coffee spots and I thought I'd
take these guys along with me I work as
a beauty influencer and leading social a
lot of foundations and thing I struggle
with I've got really skin the nice thing
about the new care line foundation is
that it is supposed to be quite flexible
in coverage so if you apply one drop to
your hand and apply that to your face
that should just give you an even light
coverage throughout the day today I'm
going to be out of the house in the
morning I'm gonna be doing back-to-back
meetings with brands and then straight
after that to in about so in all honesty
I'm not gonna have time to redo my
makeup so I'm just gonna dab it on five
points of my face and then I'm going to
blend it out from the center and I'm
using my fingers to warm up the
foundation I just think it blends nicer
so I'm using three drops of the
foundation for medium coverage the thing
I think that I'm most excited about this
foundation is that it has the no oil no
silicon and no alcohol and because I'm
starting to take better care of my skin
I think it's really important because I
wear foundation every day but I'm using
a product that doesn't have all those
things in it first of all this smells
absolutely lovely and it feels super
light on my skin so I finished the
foundation of now I'm quite tempted to
leave it just like this because my skin
looks like really glowy but you can't
tell that I'm wearing funding
looking really good they carry fresh so
now I'm going to finish the rest of my
makeup and get ready to go
[Music]
it's about midday so I've been wearing
my foundation now for around 3-4 hours
and I'm so pretty impressed with it I
look quite radiant if I do say so myself
it's lunchtime and I've had a couple of
castings and I'm so impressed with how
well this foundation is lost in so far
it still looks really fresh girl owns
definitely not a brand that I would
normally use but definitely change her
mind now so I'm just doing some shopping
at the moment I thought I'll check in
with you guys and see how my foundation
is doing as you can see it's still all
in place so I've just don't ask me to
help we've got a I've been touching my
face all day my foundation would
normally have completely disappeared
from my cheeks and my chin and my maple
would have dropped from under my eyes
I'm just gonna leave it and head
straight to the event I've been doing
insta stories and taking pictures all
day and my skin looks
comedian and Chloe even now when I'm in
a cab and it's nearly getting dark
outside and I've got a flash on even
with this bad lighting at the end of the
day and I can't go for how during
freshmen wake up still looks definitely
would recommend this foundation to
anyone that wants a natural look is
definitely a daytime foundation looks so
good on oily skin and it lasts two just
got back to the hotel after their long
it was a day I'm pretty happy with the
results for this time in the night it
still got a really smooth even coverage
and the main thing for me is the
breathability of it I can't get over how
billowy my skin looks on the fur that
this foundation is still in place it's
just been a super reliable foundation
but I'll definitely be losing again I
definitely recommend you guys go out
there get yourself this new girl our
foundation get yourself straight much
because they have so many colors and
test it out for yourself hope you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
videos like this subscribe to wk
you